I told Chris Rock I was going to the
Comedy Cellar here in New York he said
i'ma come down I said Chrissy I'm
working on some stuff come down I won
don't you think we're close and we
always give each other opinions on what
we're doing and where we feel this can
go or that can go just punch up so he
comes down he's like oh my god cat funny
I said you're going up he said yeah i'ma
try some stuff out - Chris goes up Dave
pops in later that night he ain't Chris
with air talking Chappelle comes in we
say you're going up he said yeah me and
Chris go downstairs so we can watch Dave
keeping my man Chris are excited we just
worked on new material Chris gave me
some good beats he went on I gave him
some good beats Dave went on stage it
was so good right that me and Chris just
took what we had we balled it up throws
it up we thought well we threw it in the
trash we threw it I said get it I'm so
disgusted with where my level of
thinking was after seeing where Dave was
I got to go back in the gym